I've never known life without disability.
Disability is where a physical
or mental condition or impairment
is combined with physical
or social barriers
that make it hard for a person
to do certain things
or interact with the world around them.
Disability is very diverse,
with a wide range of experiences
that can affect a person's ability
to see, move, hear, learn,
communicate or interact with others.
In my case, my sister Erin is autistic
and has intellectual disabilities.
She processes the world differently.
She enjoys riding her bike,
collecting rubber ducks,
watching YouTube videos on repeat
and spending the money she earns at work.
When she's really happy,
she squeals and claps her hands.
Though, for many people Erin is different,
she is my normal.
In my family, we were raised
with the core value
that different is not less.
But it was made clear to me
that the rest of the world
didn't always share this value.
Like, I'll never forget,
one time in middle school,
my sister's aid had made a video
of her learning how to communicate
using speech and sign
and thriving in an inclusive classroom
where she was loved
and accepted just for who she is.
And I brought it to school,
wanting to share,
to give my classmates the opportunity
to learn more about autism,
only to be told by my teacher
that the faculty had decided against it
to "protect" me from other students
inevitably making fun of her.
It was one of many instances
that taught me what stigma was.
With every rude comment,
when Erin would have a sensory
meltdown in a public place,
with every casual use of the slur retard,
by even childhood friends of mine
with every judgmental stare,
I learned that the rest of the world
didn't necessarily see Erin
for the full human being that she is.
Now, when I went off to college,
I didn't know what role, if any,
disability would play
in my life outside my family.
It wasn't until I studied abroad in China
for my International Relations major
that my personal background
with disability
and my career came together.
Through a class I was taking
on social issues in Beijing,
I had the opportunity to visit
an autism school there
and was introduced to a local
disability rights advocacy organization.
I ended up interning with them
and got completely absorbed
into that community.
I was finally able to see
how my family's struggle
was part of something much larger,
and the magnitude of what I found
actually shocked me.
Over a billion people,
an estimated 15 percent
of the world's population,
have some form of disability.
And persons with disabilities
as a group worldwide
face huge amounts of stigma
and disadvantage.
Just to use education as an example,
of the 240 million children
with disabilities in the world,
about 50 percent
have never been to school.
I was appalled that I had been studying
global human rights
at an Ivy League school,
and even though the problem
was so unbelievably huge,
not once had disability
really ever come up.
So I decided to pivot,
and I've spent the past decade
in my career to disability inclusion
in international development.
I returned to China
on a Fulbright scholarship
to do research on education and programs
for autistic adolescents and adults.
I then went on to do research
or work with disability organizations
in places like Tanzania,
Ireland and South Africa.
I now work globally with Special Olympics,
using sport as a platform to teach
and promote inclusive attitudes.
And what I found
is that all over the world,
even though countries' specific cultural
context or systems might be different,
the underlying problem
of attitude barriers remains the same.
And the research backs me up.
The second most cited barriers
to inclusion, after lack of data,
is negative attitudes towards disability.
What people don't realize
is that exclusion hurts everyone.
The International Labour Organization
estimates that disability exclusion costs
low- and middle-income countries
between three and seven percent of GDP.
But the opposite is also true.
Inclusion could help everyone.
Our research at Special Olympics has found
that inclusive sport
and youth leadership programming
has benefits for youth,
both with and without disabilities,
especially when it comes to developing
key social and emotional skills
everyone needs to succeed
in an increasingly diverse
and interconnected world.
And this has held true in countries
as different as the United States,
China, India, Kenya and Greece.
The good news is
there are four things we all can do
to make the future more inclusive.
Number one,
we need to reevaluate
our own attitudes towards disability.
I still get questions
about whether it is "realistic"
to include persons with disabilities
in international development programs
when even the so-called
regular people are struggling.
There are still too many stereotypes
that associate disability with pity,
and we're still living with social systems
and physical structures
that segregate people with disabilities.
So fewer people have it as part
of their everyday experience,
and it still makes them
really uncomfortable.
We need to re-evaluate these attitudes.
Needing accommodation or support
does not make a person any less deserving
of dignity and respect.
This is a matter of justice
and equity, not charity.
Second, choose to include.
Solving this issue is not
just a matter of policy.
There are plenty of countries
that have disability laws on the books
or have signed and ratified
the United Nations Convention
on the Rights of Persons
with Disabilities,
but there is still a huge gap
between what is written in policy
and what actually happens in practice.
And this comes down to all of us.
We can put pressure on governments
to make sure that laws
are actually implemented.
But we can also look at where
we have the power to effect change.
We should be looking at organizations'
diversity, equity and inclusion strategies
and see where we can be doing better.
Too often we still fall short
of recognizing disability
as part of human diversity.
We would all benefit
by not only accommodating
but actively supporting and including
persons with disabilities
in the workplace.
Third, we need to recognize
where disability intersects
with every issue area.
When we talk about gender equity,
we need to be inclusive
of women with disabilities
who are actually more likely
to be victims of gender-based violence.
When we talk about global health
and health systems,
we need to be inclusive
of persons with disabilities
who are more likely to have
poor health outcomes,
often not because of their
actual disability
but because of stigma
and lack of access to care.
Everyone has something they can do
to make their work more inclusive.
And together,
these collective efforts can result
in the cultural shift that we need.
Finally, and most importantly,
don't just listen to me.
Listen to persons
with disabilities themselves.
All over the world,
there are incredible self advocates.
Like my friend and colleague Ben,
who is both legally blind
and has intellectual disability
and who successfully advocated
to the DC Department of Transportation
to get voice and sound added
to the crosswalks near our office
to make it safe for him
and people like him
to cross the street going to work.
Or Brina from the Philippines,
whose parents were told
upon her Down syndrome diagnosis
that they shouldn't set
their expectations too high,
but who has become
an assistant preschool teacher
and a UNESCO champion
for inclusion in education.
Or Haseeb, who has actually been
on a TEDx stage before me
to speak out against the stigma
he has faced as an autistic young person
in Pakistan.
And I could go on and on and on
with others who have shared
their lived experience of disability
in books, speeches, blogs,
podcasts and social media.
When you're looking for ways
to make your work more inclusive,
seek out the voices
of persons with disabilities.
Really take the time to listen
to what they have to say
and follow their lead.
Disability has always been
and will always be a part of my life.
Erin and I deserve to live in a world
where she has more opportunities
to be supported and included.
Erin, Ben, Brina and Haseeb are only four
out of over a billion people
who are just trying to find belonging
and live their best lives
in a world that was not designed for them.
Indeed, a world that was designed
to hold them back.
Not because it had to be that way,
but because people built systems
around attitudes
that other and exclude them.
And all of those people
have family members like me
whose lives are shaped by this issue
and communities who are affected,
whether they realize it or not.
Disability inclusion is not something nice
that we do for those people.
It is something critical
that needs to come from all of us.
Thank you.
(Applause)